qu'est ce qu'une blanche est très
présente et là alors un whip il ya qu à
une soirée exceptionnelle lui mars à
l'occasion du v day donc de nombreuses
personnalités seront théâtre de paris
alors le le jour du vc le jour du vagin
c'est ça non en fait c'est une choix qui
avait un jour du vagin moi un jour qui
est fait pour pour pour lutter contre
toutes ces femmes qui ne sont pas aimés
comme et comme les valentins c'est pour
pour dans les fonds sont reversés
justement à des associations qui
s'occupent de femmes battues mal traitée
à travers le monde et c'est une c'est
une association c'est un mouvement qui a
été initiée par eve ensler justement
qu'ils occupent
l'auteur des monologues du vagin qui se
bat depuis cinq ans à travers le monde
pour justement aider à la condition
féminine et et et se battre pour elle
mon clavier
on va vous laisser vivre je suis désolé
mais il faut que l'ags tu vas t'on
sincérité
à bientôt vernis
et